what's up guys so nowadays SD cards are
very popular they come inside cameras
you can use them with your consoles they
have many applications but many PCs and
laptops don't come with the SD card
reader so you have to end up buying an
adapter I use the adapter so today I
have a separate USB 2 SD card reader and
let's we're gonna unbox it and see how
it performs so let's jump right in so
guys here's a segment SD card reader
they're just a little flap on top that
comes straight off and inside this
little tab there's a little part about
reviewing
here's little manual
manual
and finally here's the SD card reader
itself the bottom you push it out and
comes right out
that's a nice little car on top
and here's the SD card reader itself now
what's nice about this SD card reader is
that has a little micro SD card reader
as well or an anime SD card reader that
way you don't have to have an SD card
reader adapter anything like that you
just plug it straight in there well guys
as for how it works it's very simple
you're just plugging the USB dongle into
the USB port your computer and put an SD
card that's it it's as simple as that
well guys I hope you guys enjoyed that
quick unboxing an overview of the same
print SD card reader that's all I have
for you guys now so if you guys like
this video make sure to give it a like
if you guys loved it and would like to
see more videos just like this make sure
that is escribe and hit that Bell
notification but that's all I have for
you guys right now and until the next
video bye